- [Mark] All right, Sasha.
- Yes
- [Mark] Sasha where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Originally, I was born in
South Sudan and I grew up in Minneapolis.
I came to America in 2004,
so I grew up in Minneapolis.
- [Mark] So you came
to America at what age?
- At five.
- [Mark] Five years old.
- Yes.
- [Mark] And you had both your parents?
- My mom and my stepdad.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- Well, growing up, it was very different
with the culture and things like that.
When I came to America, neither one of me
or my parents understood
English or anything like that.
So it was very different to learn
to adapt to the American
culture and things like that.
But I got it quick.
I understood it.
And growing up it was, I grew
up in a kind of an abusive home.
My stepfather was
abusive towards my mother
and I physically, verbally,
emotionally, all that.
So, eventually, my mom got tired of that
and ended up going to a shelter,
a battered woman's shelter.
And from there, my mom got on her feet,
was working
finding a job and was able
to find her own place for us.
And while I was, it was while growing up
my mom had a boyfriend
and during the period of
time he was living with us,
he sexually assaulted me
on multiple occasions.
So, when I was eight years old
I had my virginity taken away from me.
So, that started messing with my head.
And so I started looking at life
at a very different
point of view and looking
at myself at a different point
of view and lowering myself
to a different standard
than other kids around me.
- [Mark] How do you think it affected you?
It made you feel less worthy?
- Less worthy, it made
me feel like, well, like
what am I- I wasn't like, I'm not nothing.
Like if a grown man
doesn't have any respect
on a child, then like what?
Like, what am I here for?
You know, I'm not really worth nothing.
Who can protect me
if an adult can't protect me?
Like, I'm just out here lost in the world.
So, yeah.
- [Mark] Did you feel
like that played a role
in you ending up working
Figueroa street now?
- Most definitely.
Because it's like, if at that age
people are sleeping with me why not,
you know, put a price on it?
Why not?
You know, I'm not going to be nothing.
If that's all men look at
me as an objective growing
up without a father and
just having a mother
I never really had a
perfect male role model
in my life that, you know,
showed me that what a male is
how he's supposed to treat
a woman, respect a woman.
I've never seen it in
my mom's relationships
or in any relationships that
I've had personally growing up.
So it was very hard for me to trust a man
or even allow a man to get that close
to me because I always
thin it's some bullshit.
- [Mark] So do you recall your
very first time of doing this?
- Um, yes. I was
about 16.
A friend had actually
introduced me into the game
and she didn't really like,
say nothing much of it.
Like, you know, we're just going
to go in here and, you know
just talk to this guy and you know
he's going to give you
this or for whatever.
And that was that.
And from then on, I just went with it
and I was already running away from home
and didn't really have a stable
home and things like that.
So it's like, I was
out in the streets anyways,
fighting for myself.
So why not?
I need money, I need food, I need shelter,
I need clothes, things like that.
All the necessities so, why not?
- [Mark] Have you had bad
experiences out there?
- Hmm?
- [Mark] Have you had bad experiences
with working the street?
- Yeah.
Ran into a couple people
that were not, you know...
I have had people try to
hurt me, try to kidnap me,
things like that.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Have you been arrested before?
- Yes.
Yeah. Once in jail, actually,
when I started coming out
working in LA was the
first time I went to jail
for prostitution and yeah, that was,
that was not great.
I didn't like that.
- [Mark] Were you doing
this in Minneapolis as well?
- Yeah
But Minneapolis, we don't have streets.
Everything is online or
on the internet and things like that.
Or girls are working in the clubs.
But Minneapolis, we don't have no streets
or nothing like that where girls can just
go work and things.
- [Mark] How much money
were you making a night?
- Varies. Depending on
if it's a slow night could
be seven to a thousand.
- [Mark] Are you saving money?
- Do I save money?
- [Mark] Yeah
- Yes. Yeah.
I want I'm I wanna, you
know, start modeling.
I wanna, I wanna be an entrepreneur.
And help me start my own business.
I want to help people.
I wanna like, just like
I don't know, help girls,
young teens, anybody just get
out the situation of homelessness,
any struggles, you know?
To open doors because I
know how it is growing
up as a young youth, being homeless
being out in the streets,
not having nowhere to go
things like that and that without you know
that without having a home or
things like that, it's like
you're just out here doing whatever.
And kids getting into gang banging,
kids getting into prostitution,
kids getting into robbing,
feeling all those types of things.
And it's just like,
I want to be able to help my people.
Save them from that before
they get to that route.
- [Mark] Right.
- [Mark] Does your family
know that you do this?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And what do they say?
- My mother does, but
I mean, what can she really say?
She could just pray and hope that
- [Mark] I mean, with the childhood abuse
that you went through and then
the family you had almost led
you down this path, right?
- Yeah. Not really a lot of support, so..
- [Mark] Does it get you down sometimes?
Do you get depressed?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Like going back to my room
and just sometimes you
just feel alone, you know?
But
it's like, you just
got to keep going, like
you know what your purpose
is, so you can't stop.
But yeah, it gets to a person.
Yeah. It gets too much at one time.
It gets overwhelming.
But I mean,
you gotta survive.
You gotta figure it out.
You gotta make it one way or another.
- [Mark] And you have no kids.
You're young, right?
- I have a three year old son.
- [Mark] Oh, you do?
How old are you?
- I'm 21.
- [Mark] 21. Are you raising your son?
- Yeah. He's like, well, my
mom, with my mom right now.
So I'm going back to Minnesota on Friday.
His birthday is on the 17th of this month.
- [Mark] So he's back in Minnesota?
- Mhm, he's not here.
No, I come, I fly out here to work.
And then I go back to Minnesota, go back.
- [Mark] So, you still
live in Minneapolis?
- Mhm
Did you feel like you have a little bit
of a victim mentality because
of the things that happened to you?
- No. Cause I don't, I
don't let that hold me back.
Yeah. Because if I sit
and play a victim, just be
in my own pity and stuff
like that, I'm not going to
move nowhere.
I'm going to be stuck.
So I, I try to make these as
a stepping stone, like, okay
you know what I'm saying?
Like, I'm not the only one,
everybody facing things in life
but it's up to us to, you
know, make a difference
on how we want our lives to go.
I'm the only one I can make a difference.
You know, the things
that happened to me, it
happened. But
- [Mark] Have you
considered talking to
a therapist about it?
- Yeah, I've had therapy.
- [Mark] You have? Was that helpful?
- Yeah.
It did.
It was good.
But
there, we can only do so much
and, at the end of the day.
It all falls back on the person
and how they want to move on
and how they're gonna take
what, you know, take these
whatever it is that comes
to them and, you know
turn it around and how they plan it.
- [Mark] Does the fast money
of the street become addictive?
You think?
- No, because well, for me
personally is not because I would
I would rather have a nine to five job
and know that I have
consistent income come in.
I have a reliable, you know, I'm
I'm gonna make it to work safely
and I'm going to make it back home safely.
Whereas this, this is a risk.
This is a every night you go outside
you're taking chances going
in these clients' cars.
You don't know what could happen.
Going with these people
to people's houses.
It's just a lot of
risks and going to jail.
That's not, it's not worth it.
Yeah. It's not worth it.
When it comes down to
when everything comes down
to it, the money is fun.
Yup. You can, it's good money, whatever.
You can go do this.
You know, girls like to
go get their hair done
on trips, whatever, whatever, whatever.
But when it's all said and over with
how do you really feel like
money can't buy happiness.
It can't.
And if you're not happy,
then it's not for-
What is it?
What are you doing it for?
What's the purpose, right.
Can't be a hoe forever.
At the end of the day,
we're going to get old, saggy,
And it's going to be another little girl
turn 18 and come out
here and just, you know
so it's like, what's your purpose?
The money's good.
But what's the purpose?
What are you doing this for?
Why are you out here?
Because every day you're taking a risk
and giving yourself to somebody like
- [Mark] Do you feel like doing this
to generate money has
affected the way you see men?
- Yeah, a little bit.
I mean, I've always had my
guard up since I was a child, so
relationships with men, it's-
right now
I think it's not really
an appropriate time
for me to even try to consider
myself being with anybody
like that, because I have
to get myself fully together
and I have a child that I'm raising.
So those two are my number two priorities.
And I can't give myself
to somebody without taking
care of myself first.
- [Mark] Have you met a male figure?
Who is a stand-up guy?
Who, who isn't-
- Who I'd be interested in?
(laughing)
- [Mark] Well, not necessarily
that you're interested in
but maybe he could be
interesting or maybe he's not
- Not right now, I haven't.
- [Mark] No, but, have you ever met
anybody who is like
a guy that you respect
and see that his motives are
pure and stuff like that.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] They exist.
Just, probably not for me.
(laughing)
- [Mark] Why not for you?
- Um, I don't know.
I think, I don't know.
I guess I just don't know what I want yet.
That's probably what I'm doing by myself
(laughing)
- [Mark] Well, you have
to, you have to be able
to accept a guy like that before you will.
- Yeah. And that's why
I'm saying, I just still
- [Mark] you're still
struggling with that.
- Yeah. Well my stuff, not
necessarily the other person.
- [Mark] Yeah. And you're 24 years old
- 21
- [Mark] 21, I'm sorry, even younger.
You're a, you've got a long way to go.
And so you're still a kid.
- Pretty much.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have any dreams
of where you'd like to
be in, in your future?
- Um
In my future?
- [Mark] You mentioned
like helping others.
- Hopefully, yeah.
With, my entrepreneur business, if I
if I'm starting modeling
I hope I see myself just giving back
to my community in Minneapolis.
I see myself helping, helping people.
I see myself going back
to Africa with my family.
I just see myself just being a mother
taking care of my son and being
at home with him and giving
him my time and my energy.
- [Mark] Do you think the
the way that your parents raised you
helps you or hurts you in terms of
the way you're raising your child?
- Um, It helps because I learned a lot
of great qualities from my
mom, because like I said
my mom came from another foreign country
and was able to make it
and did not use no excuse.
She's a nurse right now.
She has her own place,
like everything like that.
So she's always prospered
through all, everything.
Like she's never let nothing-
she's never sat and played
the victim, basically.
Like she's been abused- a lot of stuff.
You know, she doesn't have nobody.
It's just me and her in America.
We don't- my grandma, her siblings
everybody is still back in Africa.
So
she, she's a very strong woman
and that's the greatest quality.
Like, now I'm gonna carry over
to my child and that's
why I haven't stopped.
And that's why I haven't used this
as an excuse because my mom didn't stop.
So I know it's some greater
for me in this world too.
So I'm gonna keep going till I get it.
(laughing)
- [Mark] All right, Sasha.
Sasha, thank you so
much for talking with me
and good luck with your
future and your, and your son.
- Thank you! (laughs)
- [Mark] Let me ask you one more question.
I guess I can edit these together.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Um, do you use drugs at all?
- No
- [Mark] You stay away from all that?
- Yeah. I drank occasionally,
but I tried to not.
- [Mark] Do you have to be
drunk to do this sometimes?
- No! (laughs)
- [Mark] No?
- No, I just like, I like
to like, you know, like get
in my mode, like, you know,
like just a little drink
or whatever, but I'm not, I
try to, because at the end
of the day you have to
be, you have to be aware
of your surroundings.
You have to be aware of
everything that's going on.
So if you're high or even
drunk, if something happens
you know, and it's a lot
of situations where girls
are intoxicated and get robbed
or get raped or get in
anything like, and that's scary
- [Mark] Do you use your intuition
with the guys you pick up?
- Yeah
- [Mark] Sometimes you just
say, this one feels bad.
- Mhm, I would do a lot
because sometimes people be
like, "Girl, why you didn't go?"
Because I just feel it
like, sometimes that's why
I say the money's not worth it sometimes.
Like, sometimes you just
feel like he's not really-
this might be a sticky situation.
It's okay to just leave that
little money right there.
So yeah
that's for the most
part, that's what I go by
because I've been in lot
of situations where it
may seem like it's good.
He may have a nice car, the best money
but then his attitude is
disgusting and now I'm
fucked up.
Yeah.
- [Mark] All right.
Thank you so much.
- Mhm!